♪♪
Narrator:
TO MAKE THE DIVING-BOARD SHELL,
WORKERS LOAD A SHEET OF ACRYLIC
INTO A CLAMPING MACHINE
THAT TRANSPORTS IT INTO AN OVEN.
THE OVEN HEATS THE SHEET FOR
ABOUT 30 SECONDS TO SOFTEN IT.
THEN, A FORMING MACHINE
APPLIES SUCTION
TO DRAW THE SOFTENED ACRYLIC
TIGHTLY OVER A MOLD
IN THE SHAPE
OF TWO DIVING BOARDS.
FANS BLOW COOL AIR,
HARDENING THE ACRYLIC
TO THIS SHAPE WITHIN SECONDS.
THEY EXTRACT THE MOLDED ACRYLIC,
THEN SAW IT IN HALF TO SEPARATE
THE TWO DIVING-BOARD SHELLS.
THEY COAT THE SHELL SURFACE IN
A RESIN-AND-FIBERGLASS MIXTURE.
THIS TOOL
IS CALLED A CHOPPER GUN
BECAUSE IT CHOPS AND SHREDS
THE FIBERGLASS STRING,
THEN SHOOTS IT OUT
DRENCHED IN RESIN.
THEY ROLL IT TO COMPRESS THE
FIBERS AND PUSH OUT AIR POCKETS.
ANY TRAPPED AIR WOULD CREATE
A WEAK SPOT IN THE DIVING BOARD.
AFTER LETTING THE RESIN DRY
AND HARDEN FOR 30 MINUTES,
THEY BEGIN
FILLING THE SHELL CAVITY
WITH .2-INCH THICK
FIBERGLASS MAT.
THEN THEY LAY DOWN
ANOTHER FIBERGLASS MAT,
THIS ONE A BIT THINNER
AND SATURATED
WITH THE EXISTING RESIN.
THE DIVING BOARD'S CORE
IS MADE OF LAMINATED WOOD,
WHICH IS SEVERAL THIN LAYERS
OF WOOD GLUED TOGETHER.
LAMINATED WOOD
IS ACTUALLY STRONGER
THAN A SOLID PIECE OF WOOD.
AFTER ROUNDING THE TOP EDGE,
THEY LAY TWO WOOD-LAMINATE CORES
OVER THE RESIN-SATURATED
FIBERGLASS MATS.
THEY POSITION CLAMPS
TO HOLD THE CORES IN PLACE,
THEN LET THE RESIN CURE
AT ROOM TEMPERATURE
FOR A HALF HOUR OR SO.
THEN THE CLAMPS COME OFF,
AND WORKERS COVER THE CORES
WITH AN EVEN THICKER FIBERGLASS
MAT IMPREGNATED WITH RESIN.
THIS IS THE BOTTOM
OF THE DIVING BOARD.
THEY MAKE SURE
THE MAT IS CENTERED...
...THEN MANUALLY FORM IT
TO THE SHAPE OF THE BOARD,
PUSHING OUT THE AIR POCKETS
AS THEY GO.
THEY SPRAY ON
SOME DECORATIVE PAINT,
THEN PUT THE BOARD IN AN OVEN
FOR 24 HOURS TO CURE.
WHEN IT COMES OUT,
THEY USE A DIAMOND BLADE
TO SAW OFF THE EXCESS FIBERGLASS
AROUND THE EDGE.
THEN THEY DO A FINAL TRIMMING
TO MAKE THE EDGE
NEAT AND SMOOTH.
THEY MASK THE SIDES WITH TAPE,
LEAVING ONLY THE TOP EXPOSED.
THIS IS WHERE THEY'LL NOW APPLY
A ROUGH TEXTURE --
A SAFE, NON-SLIP SURFACE.
FIRST, THEY ROLL ON
A THIN COAT OF RESIN.
ONTO THAT, THEY SPRINKLE A LAYER
OF SILICA SAND,
MAKING SURE TO COVER THE SURFACE
THOROUGHLY AND EVENLY.
THE SAND STICKS TO THE RESIN,
WHICH SETS AND CURES
IN ABOUT 15 MINUTES.
AFTER SWEEPING OFF THE
EXCESS SAND THAT DIDN'T ADHERE,
THEY ROLL ON A COAT
OF LAMINATING RESIN,
WHICH BONDS TO THE SAND,
GIVING THE SURFACE
A CLEAN, FINISHED LOOK.
THEY PULL OFF THE TAPE
AND APPLY THE MANUFACTURER'S
DECAL TO THE SIDE.
THE DIVING BOARD IS NOW ALL SET
TO BE INSTALLED
ON A STAND
AT THE EDGE OF THE DEEP END
TO AWAIT ANYONE
READY TO TAKE THE PLUNGE.